when you look at the sheer tribalism you
know like i mentioned and
and many people have mentioned joe biden
seems to only be talking to one side of
the country at this point because
they've basically resigned themselves
okay we can't win them over it's over
we're done we're done talking
i mean the the tribalism has reached
absolutely absurd levels you know it's
like that right now that people are
people are circulating these old tweets
from 2020
of kamala harris and like daily coast
writing about vaccine skepticism
and they're saying like who would take
trump's vaccine and now they're the ones
screaming like why won't trump
supporters take the right
absolutely yeah people are absolutely
aligned i
i gotta say you know perhaps i'm just
biased but
i think it is fair to say that it is
indeed it is it is uh
the rule for the establishment left but
the exception
for the right in general so leftists
kind of overlap with a lot of the
establishment democrats
but you look at you mention the
republican party in the in their you
know forever war kind of stuff too
i want to make clear that i don't think
that's just the republicans i mean both
parties
are forever but i will say like i think
as as another sign of the of of the
collapse or the decay or the change
whatever you want to call it is donald
trump's storming into the republican
party and forcing dramatic changes
right and trump supporters he couldn't
have done that in 1980 or 1984
you can't uh one man with a bunch of
bombast can't knock over a healthy
system
but the trump supporters i i don't know
if you
did you hear what michael moore said
back in 2016. i think i did i remember
being shocked that he was sort of
intellectually honest about it for the
first time
it was it was brilliant he basically
said that trump was one of the only
people advocating for these factories
he goes to these auto manufacturers and
said i will i will tear a few 30
if you try and move these cars out of
america and and then
michael moore said the workers look at
donald trump like
like a human molotov cocktail and they
are going to send the biggest
few to the establishment the world has
ever heard and they are going to enjoy
it
the one thing he got wrong was he was
like it'll feel good for a week
or a month i felt good for four years i
know yeah it felt good for a lot of
people for a while
so i think that's one of the big changes
the republican party but i think
you know uh so just to address that
point on the left you have many people
who are
it's it's crazy how they can't remember
what they said last year you know i uh
started flipping back through 1984
recently and everyone's read 1984.
and and there's a problem with reading
things you tend to boil them down to an
essence or
a logo or something and and things in
the world books
novels people uh have a whole lot of
complexity so
to actually go back and look at 1984 um
it's
not just sort of a stand-in or a
stereotype or a glyph
that stands for repressive
totalitarianism there's a lot of
detail there and the detail about how
the party just changes
the line and everyone you know switches
on a dime
and this is what we're seeing um you
know last year
you know i was one of these internet
autists who was paying attention to
china
in very very early january and i think
it was late january
when you know i started tweeting my ten
thousand you know i'm talking to tim
pool about i've got ten thousand
followers on twitter
um but i i said you know guys now is the
time to start packing uh stockpiling
stuff and people said you know what and
i said
you know i don't know that you know if
it surfaces but start getting latex
gloves in case it does turn out to be
surfaces i don't know if it's airborne
but definitely start getting masks you
know p90 p95
start laying in food i'm not saying
there will be supply chain disruptions
but when you don't know
and at that time the left and uh oh gosh
what was he uh
ezra um yes thank you i think it was
either ezra klein or if it wasn't hezer
klein it was one of the other ezra
kleins
was absolutely poo pooing this idea of
you know masks do nothing and even if
they do anything you should leave it for
the professionals there's no reason to
have a mask
and the fear that you'll generate that's
the real danger and then they all pivot
on a dime
when you know the new line comes down
from the you know there used to be
journalists if you're familiar with that
you know
what the journalists the journalists oh
yeah there's more than people know man
right and and so certainly there are
dozens more journalists and
when you see so let's let's break that
down real quick he's not saying
journalist he's saying journal hyphen
list
this was i think ezra klein made this
right
it was a it was a facebook group where
all of these different journalists from
different organizations were on
one community group together so one
person would come in and say x happened
and then every single journalist would
you know in this group would see it
so they were all wrapped up in the exact
same bubble narrative
completely oblivious to the outside
world there's a wonderful video on
youtube
that shows uh some people on a cable
channel reading out a prepared statement
and like every five second it switches
to a different cable channel and the
statement continues seamlessly
because this was literally a memo that
came down from corporate and they wanted
every local affiliate to do it
journalist was effectively the same
thing but there wasn't a corporation at
the top there was just this little
plate or file or hive of journalists and
they had tomorrow's bullet points every
day so people don't realize about that
is
there wasn't one journal list there was
probably ten thousand
right i was personally on several of
them yeah i think i worked on one
i was on i was on there there were a
bunch of red ones there was one that was
about it was like um
citizen journalist centric so it was
basically
10 or 20 000 people with several who are
very active and many who just followed
and they would post things and they
would all see it and then sure enough
these articles pop up everywhere
but i i do want to with that being said
go back to the point you're making about
you know it's time to prepare it's time
to buy supplies because
early early on last year you know we we
have one one of the sponsors we often do
is for a food bucket awesome safe and
ready meals
this is not i'm not promoting them i'm
just mentioning that we have from them
in the past
and this is like a 25-year food bucket
now i
i don't i don't like doing promos like
legit people like i'll get sent like hey
tim would you want to advertise for this
and i'm like no i can't do that company
you know like i have to actually think
there's utility there
and so this company i thought was
actually fantastic because
the way i describe it to people is you
know you've got a first aid kit right
i've got multiple first of all right how
many but i don't know four or five
including trauma bandages
um i go into that in my books in that uh
you know i've got a small first aid kit
in my workshop
i've got a beefier first aid kit in my
chainsaw supplies
all right now now here's a question
though sure how often do you use them
uh you know there's sort of the 80 20
rule or the power law
and that you know i probably cut my
fingertips or something every you know
two weeks or so i i think i actually did
it once every two weeks
yeah you might need advantage right how
often do you eat food
right yeah you know i think you eat food
yes three times a day
and so it's crazy to me that you know
that there's this negative connotation
uh this negative perspective on
having emergency food or whatever and
i'm like you should have a thing of
water food
and a first aid kit and and you know you
look at what happened with those around
the time a camera actually i don't
remember when this was there was
flooding in houston you know it was
really really good
and i'm like some of these people are
like trapped in their houses for a long
period of time
you're gonna be happy you can crack open
that freeze-dried sealed bag and
now you need some power to to boil the
water and stuff like that you know
but i look at it like it was strange to
me that the establishment
doesn't prepare for anything right you
know you mentioned they turn on a dime
the the the party says so be it and they
all just agree
and they're all in this mentality that
no matter what happens they will always
be safe and that to me is insane
absolutely i look you know you know what
i think here's what i always say about
buying beans and rice or these emergency
food kits
if you're in your absolute worst case
scenario
okay admittedly your worst case you have
food right you know but in the absolute
best case scenario
you literally you just eat it yeah like
i used to say look worst case scenario
just eat the food right then i realize
no the worst case scenario would be the
actual apocalypse and then you'll eat
the food right
but if you buy these things and then
nothing happens i
the other day i just cracked it open
made some stroganoff it was delicious
put some chicken in there and some
spices
and i've absolutely done the same thing
not recently but you know i've had a
pile
you know one or two boxes of mres
sitting around the house forever since
you know shortly after i got out of
college
and uh you know every now and then you'd
be sort of working late and suddenly
it's
uh 10 o'clock and there's no food in the
fridge and there's no take out you know
i've eaten an mre at 10 30 in the
evening more than once yeah
you know it's not something you want to
eat all the time right they're not bad
yeah it's good self-limiting in that way
you're never going to be tempted to eat
up all of your
eyes but let's talk let's talk about
this you know right now
you mentioned in the previous segment
that we could be coming to this
five-year
500-year end cycle i mean you've heard
of the fourth turning yeah yeah yeah you
said he's trapped and now we've got that
mit
study that everyone's talking about 2040
the clash is coming or whatever
there's yet another one i'm going to
mispronounce the word but it's like
coral of wave theory
and we should add it to the list we can
talk about that one you know i i think i
ended up picking this up from
a an interstitial essay in a book of uh
john barnes short stories like 30 years
ago um
and the idea is that there's a bunch of
different way of sort of sinusoids and
some have four-year
cycles another 12. and you know at some
point if you've ever you know taken
calculus or done a for a you know
decomposition of something
you get a whole bunch of curves and they
start to peak up at certain points
and um you know the theory is that all
of these curves are going to peak uh
you know sometimes way off in the far
future like 2025 or something
and you know this theory is written down
in the 70s or 80s and
i i think we're seeing a lot of it come
true you know stuff is getting crazy so
do you think you know you mentioned last
year you said people should buy stuff
yeah
what would you say right now do you
think people should be stocking up or
something like that um let me
i always want a little bit and say panic
right yeah yeah um
panic never helps anything um i think
that anti-fragility is a good thing and
sort of the nesting tower love that idea
um and so you know people ask are you a
prepper i'm like well you know
i i'm not prepared to survive the zombie
apocalypse i don't want to survive a
nuclear war
you don't want to you know i'm saying
maybe for humor
i'd rather not die if there's a nuclear
war um but the point is all sorts of
things happen and it's always better to
be prepared for them
one thing i talked about just you know
this isn't a survivalist or a prepper
book um
and i've got some sort of anti-prepping
thought and that's escape from the city
right
escape from the city and uh this is a
recent homesteading uh book that i wrote
i've been on the homestead for eight
years
and there's two volumes volume one and
volume two wow
and uh it's basically one long book
about thirteen hundred pages long
and the uh you know it's sort of massive
in the amount of detail inside
uh you know the table of contents alone
is 30 pages so if you've got any
interest
in homesteading or uh prepping um i'd
recommend picking it up
uh it's escape the city it's on amazon
and
they made prepping a dirty word yeah um
you know
the problem with anything is that it
gets an ideological stink
um and so there's always this constant
recycling of language whether it's the
name of for a minority
or um you know intellectually challenged
person or a hobby you know
um and so you know prepping uh there's
always uh an impetus in the media to
find someone and point at them and laugh
and then everyone laughs along with you
and you know sort of the journalist
goes out that we all agree as a society
that you know preppers or furries or
whatever you know
we can punch down at them because
they're a bunch of weirdos in the same
way that we're punching down at people
who are buying masks last
january so anyway
my thoughts about prepping are there's a
power law in that
absolute huge catastrophic things happen
very very rarely but sort of very small
annoyances happen more often so if
someone says you know i want to be
prepared what should i do should i get a
zombie hunter extreme machete should i
get a long-range sniper rifle i'm like
you know maybe you should get 500 in the
checking account because
uh you know people get laid off like
once every five years so you're gonna be
laid off from your job
you know in the next five years
certainly in the next ten years so lock
down how you're going to survive that
without you know
losing your lifestyle um you know people
lose their power once every 10 or 15
years plan for that and that's not
expensive you get a 500
generator 300 transfer switch um but
then you keep going out on these things
and they're less and less
frequent um but the chance you know
hopefully we'll all live to be 70 or 80
or 90. and a thing that only happens
once every 15 years that's gonna happen
to you several times in your life
and we in the west we've been you know
rich and protected by oceans and so
we've been
uh very you know blessed and we've not
had a lot of the bad stuff that normal
people have at the same
rate that they have it but i wrote this
book starting several years ago and one
thing i said is
hey we get plagues about once every
hundred years we had the spanish flu in
1918 and i went back several other
plagues
so you should be prepared because
there's a decent chance that there'll be
a plague in your lifetime
um did you hear about uh this this story
happened several years ago there was an
algil bloom
in the great lakes and within 40 which
is toledo
on the lake i can't remember which city
it was western ohio but is
the lake cleveland sandusky's on the
lake there was within 40 miles i guess
of all these cities
no drinking water wow because what
happened was as soon as the news broke
as soon as people found out they
immediately started raiding
local stores for bottled water and
moving further and further out to get
more and more water and then within 40
miles
no water what do you drink my wife made
a really interesting point that one of
the reasons to prep is not because it's
the only way to get the supplies
the reason to prep is so that you don't
have to make terrible trade-offs when
you need the supplies
um and you know the terrible trade-off
could be as simple as paying 10
a gallon for gasoline to run your
generator or it could be a lot worse and
i mean you know
people especially women in refugee camps
all the time have to make terrible
tradeoffs
you know i went crazy with vinegar and
salt and people are laughing and honey
honey like to hunt like 100 pounds of
honey because
if it does go down i want to provide it
for the neighbors i want the entire
community to be preserved as much as
possible so we can barter so that if
they have all the ammo
if they have you know whatever so we can
all kind of come together and those
things become extremely valuable
ian bought an absurd amount of salt
vinegar and honey never go bad
and we laugh mostly at the vinegar most
of the vinegar
because like i don't know what it's what
you do with it however i do understand
it can be used for a lot of chemical
processes
so what's a funny idea that you'd have
so much vinegar because how often do you
really use it with some recipes
but in actuality it lasts forever
doesn't it as far as i know yeah
it does and i'm going to jump in and
defend ian because when you've got
vinegar you can pickle anything
so when your harvest comes in all over
four weeks but you want to store it for
the winter
you know just pile that under vinegar
and is that all you do you just put
vinegar yeah i thought you needed brine
brine is salt so ian's covered there no
exactly that's so yeah
i mean honey never goes bad right right
right right right right crystal salt is
you definitely need salt like you know
where where would you get your
salt in your diet if you're you know in
an area like this you know an appalachia
is salt naturally occurring or uh you
know you know
if there was a disaster or something and
you had to improvise uh i would go with
road salt but other than that you know
you're going to be trading
uh people who are you know bringing in
salt from the ocean salt was the
currency at
point five six thousand years ago i was
i was thinking about this earlier
because we bought some deer salt licks
oh yeah you just you know chuck them out
you leave on them or something
and i see the deers going nuts from
because there's no salt right right and
so the deer when they find salt
there's a warning on it saying make sure
you put out several otherwise the deer
will fight each other to get it
because there's no salt so imagine if
you didn't have salt see this is a crazy
thing people don't realize
in in even you know we get out of the
city we're in the middle of nowhere
people still don't realize that we're
dependent on so much like
vitamin c for instance i don't know
where we would source vitamin c
out here we could probably try and grow
some stuff maybe because we're more
modernized we can grow stuff indoors and
try and grow some citrus or something
but where would we get vitamin c what's
your recommendation um for that i
i again i'm not a super prepper but uh
rose hips have vitamin c and we've got
roses in the yard so
yeah uh you know wild rose hairs yeah
just eat a bunch of roses yeah
wow boiled into tea yep absolutely way
to do it
can you boil grass can you work with
grass for food
i know you can't eat it directly
excessive cellulite yeah i don't think
there's many calories in grass
i i would feed grass to my sheep and
then eat the sheep so
that'll work yeah yeah that's the
easiest way to do it chickens eat grass
yes they do
but they can't uh subsist off of grass
right
um you know chickens uh will get a lot
of their calories from bugs and worms
yeah and so we've got our chickens in a
pen but there's a thing that a lot of
people do which is a chicken
tractor and that has nothing to do with
a diesel powered tractor it's basically
a mobile pin with wheels on it
and the idea is that you put your
chickens in this pen and then you just
go out and either with your riding mower
your tractor or just by hand
you move it 10 or 15 feet a day chicken
city on wheels exactly
yeah people have recommended it and i've
heard that people will put it over where
they want to farm right let the chicks
chickens tear it up then move it and
then they can plant stuff in it and they
fertilize it so i've got a thought about
this and this is something i go into my
book
um there's some utility in this you know
chickens are great
pigs are great i don't have pigs this
year but in general i have pigs like
every other year
but people sometimes want to say oh man
you know and this is sort of like after
a deep
bong hit you know the system you know
nature gives you everything you need man
the pigs will furrow you know they'll
turn up the soil for you so you don't
need to till
and there's a little bit of truth here
but there's a whole lot more wishful
thinking and i've never
uh seen anyone who um says that pigs
will till your soil who actually have
their own pigs
it's uh to some degree wishful thinking
so the pigs are no good
pigs are great um but pigs do not
replace uh tractors or rototillers or
plastics yeah yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you